こんちゃす！
はじめしゃちょーです
えー我々YouTuber
↘︎というものがありましてですね
まぁ動画を出すとその動画に→
コメントをできる場所が
ありまして→
この動画をスマホで見ている方
いるとこうやって画面を→
スワイプしていってください
ま基本的には　なんですけども
YouTuberって皆さん→
コメントを↗︎
多分。
まぁまぁまぁ僕ももうYouTuber→
約7年ぐらいやってるんで
7年ぐらいやるとちょっとまぁ…
ちょっとね
ちょっと気にしなくは→
なったんですけども
動画によってはめちゃくちゃ→
コメントが気になったり→
「うわこれ
どう思われてるんだろう」→
という動画を上げた時の反応とか
すごい気になったりするんですよ
恐らくなんですけども
YouTuberは人に動画を→
見てもらいたいと思ってて動画を
出してると思うんで→
多少なりとも反響とか
皆の意見とかコメントが→
気になっていると思うんですよ
えーその中　約7年間
YouTuberやってきた私→
はじめしゃちょーが選んだ…
ってか　何なら今から選ぶ…
↘︎を紹介したいと思います
何で嬉しいコメントじゃなくて
悲しいコメントかって言うと…
ではいこう！
はいというわけで実際にコメント
見ていきましょうか
まぁでもね最近そんなひどい
悪口とかね　批判コメント→
あんまり見てないと
思うんですよね
♪〜
あー
ありましたねぇ
なんか別にこのコメントで
良い悪いじゃなくて→
純粋に悲しくなる
コメントというと
↘︎ってコメントがよく来ますね
あの　言わせてください
もったいなくはないと思います！
これなぜかと言いますと
僕　タピオカがないと…
たとえばこの動画はですよ→
大量のタピオカを床に置いてる
動画なんですけど→
これ　もったいないって
言い出すと→
動画が撮れなくなるんですよね
なぜかと言うと…
この動画に必要なもの
何だと思いますか？
そう
ってなると　あの…
わかるんですよ。
もしこれが
僕　動画回してなくて→
個人的に　プライベートで
やってたらそりゃもちろん→
僕ももったいないと思いますし→
どう見てももったいない
タピオカがもったいないって→
なるんですけど→
タピオカをああいう使い方
することによって→
1本の動画ができてる
わけですから。
なんか…もったいない…
のかな？って思っちゃいます
わかんない
それは人それぞれです！
あくまで私の意見として
受け止めておいてください
もったいないはちょっと
あのーでも　悲しいです
それをそう使わないと
できないことが多いんで。
↘︎っていうのよく
言われるんですけどぉ！
はいこれ　ちょっと　あのー
まぁしょうがないスよね
こんだけ財布無くすとさすがに
やばいと思います
こんだけ物無くすって　ちょっと
注意力の散漫さが大きすぎる→
とは思うんですけども→
本当にあのぼくも気をつけようと
思っております
で多分なんですけど
先に言っときます↗︎
もう先手必勝で言っとくんスけど
多分また無くすんで→
ネタだと思って観てください
多分動画の中のぼくは
超慌ててると思うんですけど→
でも無くす原因も
自分の中で大体わかってて→
慢性的な睡眠不足と
絶対何かやってるんスよ。
スマホのゲームに熱中してるか
動画の編集してるか→
なんか考え事してるかで→
もう自分の中ではある程度の
原因はわかってるんですけども→
どうしようもないっていうのが…
意図して無くそうとしている
わけじゃないんですけども→
無くしてしまった時は動画撮ろう
って思ってるんで！
今後ももしぼくが
財布を無くした際は→
えー
他人事だと思って
笑ってあげてください
っていうのが4位ですかねぇ
ふっっっ……
♪〜
まっ　そ…うなんですよ
フッ…ｗ
そうなんですよとしか言えんｗ
やりたいこととか思いつきは
ちょっと変わってるなって→
思うんですけども↗︎
それが上手くいくとかはちょっと
正直よくわかんないっス
上手くいっても
上手くいかなくても→
動画にしちゃってるんで→
多分その結果　上手くいかない
ことが多いんで→
なんか実験とか検証とかすると
大抵上手くいかないような→
印象がついてるのかなーって
思いますね
ちょっと寂しいかな！
でも　コメントありがとう☆
まさにこの↗︎
↘︎ってやつがそういうコメントが
ありましたね
あーこれありますね　あのー
最近　エイリアンを寝てる人の
周りにめちゃくちゃ置いて→
ドッキリする動画が
あったんですけども→
そちらのコメントにありました
こち…ら系のコメント。
あぁぁああ〜〜〜〜(泣)
悲しいです(´；ω；｀)
あ　オレじゃなくてね。
これはオレじゃなくて
多分たて面が悲しいコメントだな→
ってぼくは思っちゃいます
まぁ別にコメント欄自由なんで→
何書いてもいいと
思うんですよ正直。
これはこの…YouTuber側が
そのコメントどう思うか→
っていうのをぼくはただ徒然と
話してるだけなんですけど→
エイリアン仕掛けた人がたて面
っていうんですけども→
彼の気持ちからすると！
こんな…
「他の人の方が良かった」
「他の人に仕掛けてください」→
とか言われて悲しいと
思うんですけど→
ぼくからするとですよ。
動画を作ったぼくからすると→
エイリアンたくさん置いてね
起きないのは彼だけなんですよ。
あの子眠りがすごい深いので。
寝起きドッキリできるのは→
もうたて面しかいないので。
あのー　ぼくドッキリ仕掛ける人
一応適材適所で。
絶対この人がいいなとか　この人
じゃないとできないなとか→
色々考えた上で
チョイスしてるんで。
まぁそんな裏事情なんて
皆さんもちろんわからないと→
思うんですけど→
なんか「他の人が
良かった」とか…
「あの人のがリアクション
絶対面白い」とか言うと…
まぁ人の意見なんでそれはそれで
いいかなと思うんですけど→
書かれた本人は辛いんじゃ
ないかなぁーって思います
何書いてもいいんですけど
純粋なぼくの意見ですよ
「〜の方がいい」
「〜の方が良かった」→
「〜じゃなくて〜にして
ください」とかっていうのって…
うーん。
ちょっと悲しいよね！
そして栄えある↗︎
正直に「こいつは悲しいな」
って思うコメントは…
えー…
↘︎というコメントです。
ほろり…
いやそりゃ　まぁまぁまぁ
そうでしょうねぇ！
だって昔は…
暴れてたもんなぁ！
色々炎上するような内容とかの
動画も出してたんスけど→
昔の方が好きって言われても
こちらとしては…
まぁ悲しいちゃ悲しいですけど
昔の方が好きっていう方は→
そりゃそうなんでしょうって
思うんスけど→
まぁぼくは　昔は昔で
昔のはじめしゃちょーの良さが→
あるし　今は今で
いろんな人が増えたり。
昔と比べるとですよ。
昔の方が色んなことができたり→
してたかもしれないん
ですけども→
今は今で。
できないことも増えましたけど
逆に今だからこそできることも→
増えたと思うんで。
昔の良さも今の良さもあるんで
そこは自由なんスけど→
昔の方が好きとか
言われるとですねぇ…
正直　どうしようも
できねーなって思いますね
そういう方はぜひ　あのー　ぼく
たくさん動画出してますんで→
昔の動画をご覧ください
って感じです
昔っぽい動画　もちろん出る
かもしんないと思うんスけど→
ぼくは昔に戻れないんで。
ぼくは変化しつつ→
今後も動画出していこうと
思いますので→
よろしくお願いいたします。
はい　という感じの順位ですね！
あの正直　最近素敵なコメント
というか面白いコメント…
読んでて悲しくなるコメントが
とっても少ないんで→
なかなか　ちょっとね→
難しかったな
って思うんですけど→
最終的に私　何が言いたいかって
言いますと→
「コメントって自由だろ」って
いう意見があると思うんですよ
いう意見。
まぁたしかにコメントは自由だし
何書いてもいいし→
思ったことを書いてもいいと
思うんですけどー→
ま　それってなんか最低限の…
なんか人間としての気持ちの
配慮っていうのがまず第一に→
前提で　あるなって。
めっちゃ固いこと
言ってんなオレ！
めっちゃ固いことあるんですけど
ちょっと言わせてくださいね
ぼくが今回紹介したコメントは
全然ぼくはあの　OKだと思います
そんぐらいズバズバ言われた方が
YouTuber側からしてもちょっと
なんか嬉しいし→
全然ぼくはOKだと思います！
ただ↗︎
失敗しちゃう人とかいるんですよ
YouTuberさん。
ま　ぼくもそういう時
あったんですけどね
で　なんか　そういう人に
対する意見とかねー
なんかTwitterとか
コメント欄で見てると→
いくら自由だといっても
ちょっとそんなこと…
いくら顔が出ないからって
言いすぎでしょっていうのも多々…
あるなぁと思いまして。
まぁ　なんか　こういう
動画の際に今一度→
もしコメント欄で心無いこと
書いてる人がいたらちょっと→
1回考えてみてほしいな
って思いました！純粋に。
ちょっと自由を
履き違えてる人が…いる…
ぼくの動画だと最近
全然いないんですけど→
他の炎上されている方の
コメント欄とか見るとちょっと→
コメントの自由　意見の自由
っていうのを→
履き違えている方がいるのかな？
ってたまに思いますね
まぁネットリテラシーって
いうもんなんスけど→
なんか　すげー真面目ぶったり
いいやつぶるようなこと言うと→
コメント欄もですね　動画とか…
なんか　あたたかく
楽しい場であれば嬉しいなって→
ぼくは思います
以上！悲しいコメント
ランキングでした！
[通常ED]